-Welcome back.
I'm here with my cohost,
the one and only Shawn Mendes!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Oh, Shawn!
We love you, buddy.
Shawn's new single,
"When You're Gone," is out now.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's right.
When I do that,
it looks like your belt
kind of blinks, almost
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's interesting.
-Look at that.
Tickets for his upcoming tour,
Wonder: The World Tour,
are on sale now.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I'm excited for it.
Thank you for being my cohost.
I appreciate this.
-I'm happy to be your cohost.
-Are you liking cohosting?
-I'm loving this.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait a sec.
You like it too much?
You want to take over?
-I like it a lot.
-Do you get nervous
when you do these things?
-Yeah, definitely.
I feel more nervous here
than I did back there.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-But you just presented
at the Oscars.
You looked great, by the way.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You sounded great.
That was awesome.
-Thank you.
-Do you get nervous
when you do that?
-That was a little
nerve-wracking, yeah.
-It was.
-Yeah. Because you're
like staring.
You're looking
at Jake Gyllenhaal.
He's like right there.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Jake Gyllenhaal.
-Jake's giving you the eye,
going like,
"Okay, you better not
mess this up."
Yeah, you get a little nervous.
-Yeah.
-But when you're onstage
in front of millions of people?
-That's like --
That's just like --
-That's at home for you.
Yeah, it feels like home.
Yeah, definitely.
-That's wild.
[ Awws ]
-Yeah.
Well, last month I wanted
to ask you this question
because I saw this.
I follow Mariah Carey
on socials -- Hi, Mariah --
-Yeah.
Hi, Mariah.
-and she posted this.
I guess she sent you a text.
-She sent me a few, yeah.
-Yeah.
-That wasn't me bragging
about that.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no.
I just want to know
about this relationship, yeah.
How did you guys start texting?
I think I posted a photo like
of myself
and the caption was like,
"Listening to old
Mariah Carey songs."
-Oh, really?
-Yeah. And she reposted one,
being like, "Listening
to old Shawn Mendes,"
which was a bit confusing,
but I loved it. I was like --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But then this got
really confusing.
-It got really confusing.
-So she sent you,
on St. Patrick's Day...
-Yeah.
-...a text to your phone...
-...and then she posted
the text that she --
[ Laughter ]
She put,
on St. Patrick's Day, she put...
-What did she text me?
-"Happy Thanksgiving!!!"
[ Laughter ]
And then eventually said,
"Wrong Shawn.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry. Also, I [didn't] realize
it's not Thanksgiving."
[ Laughter ]
And you said...
-Did you find out what that
inside joke was or what is this?
-I think my initial
instinct was
to say
Happy Thanksgiving back.
-Yeah, of course.
-just because you don't --
-Also, it's Mariah Carey.
You don't mess around.
-She could mean anything.
-Yeah, sure. Of course.
Happy Thanksgiving, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But, no, it was
St. Patrick's Day, yeah.
-Yeah.
-So she has another
friend Shawn,
who she texts
Happy Thanksgiving to
on St. Patrick's Day.
[ Laughter ]
-That is confusing.
-But also, you're Canadian,
so your Thanksgiving's
a different --
-Totally different.
So I was having a real --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, a conundrum.
-I forgot where I was from,
yeah.
-Yeah.
You post a lot.
I love everything you post.
And, recently,
you got a lot of pickup
for this post that you wrote
on social media.
You were talking about like
being very truthful
and being very honest
and talking about yourself
and mental health
and where you're at.
Is that hard,
for you to to do that
and do you have people
around you that like,
"Shawn, maybe don't do that?"
-Definitely.
I mean, I don't really --
Those people don't get to see
that tweet before it comes out.
Although, I think
they would encourage it.
But I think it's kind of like
the only way for me, you know.
-Yeah.
-I could feel like
I can't do this thing
where I'm like putting on a show
or, you know, even though
we're like here and happy,
but we are genuinely here
and happy.
Like there's nothing --
-Yes, we were happy all day
today, no stress.
-Yeah, no stress,
like truly happy.
And I feel like,
although we are entertainers,
like people just kind of want
truth and they want honesty.
And that's what I want
from people,
so that's what I'm trying to --
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah.
-But I thought,
because it's like, you know,
you don't have to do that and I
commend you for doing that.
-Yeah, I would think
like the expectation, nowadays,
for people --
for like celebrities,
for anybody, for like kids --
is so high.
It's to be like thriving, 10/10,
like making tons of money,
super happy,
looking amazing and like
-Perfect.
-perfect and it's just like,
you know, Instagram and stuff,
they're not really showing
the real lives of people,
so I'm just trying to like
inject a little bit of realness
into my Instagram and Twitter
or whatever, so.
It's important, yeah.
-I appreciate you doing that.
Please keep doing that.
-I'm going to try, yeah.
-I love that.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
We know you as a musician
and I'm going to ask you,
next time you're on,
to do this, if it's true.
Were you also into magic?
Is this true?
[ Laughter ]
-I had a little bit
of a magic phase.
-You had a magic phase?
-Yeah, I did.
-Now, when, how old were you
and what did you do?
Like, "I want to be --"?
-I had like three card tricks
and one toothpick trick.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, okay. Alright.
I want to see.
What's the toothpick trick?
Can you just say what it is?
-It's going to be
really confusing,
but it's like imagine you're
holding the toothpick like this.
This is a really weird way
you hold a toothpick.
-I agree.
-You like tape it
to the back of your thumb
and I'd be holding it and be
like, "Look at the toothpick"
and I would do that
and the toothpick --
You know what I'm saying.
You know what I'm getting at.
-Yeah, that's a great trick!
-Everyone else is confused.
-No, that's a life hack
right there.
We all just learned a trick
from Shawn Mendes.
That's amazing.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-That's why I'm not a magician.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but I want to talk
about the tour, though.
You're going to go on tour.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
This is Wonder" The World Tour,
kicks off in June.
This is a very climate-positive
tour, by the way
-Totally, completely.
[ Cheering ]
-that you're doing.
I love that you're doing this.
-Have to.
-Urging everyone, carpool,
et cetera, do whatever you can.
-Whatever you can.
-We want to do this
for a long time, guys.
We want to be on this Earth,
performing for a long time
and cohosting for a long time.
-Coming back every year.
-You know what I'm saying?
Come on. We have to do it.
-Let's do it. Let's do it.
-I'm amazed when you come on
because you couldn't be
a nicer guy.
This is not a fake
Shawn Mendes right here.
You're the same
as you are off-camera
as you are here.
-And you are, too.
-No, but then you get out there
and you get your guitar
and it's like pchoo!
[ Laughter ]
And it's just like
a rocket ship, man,
and it's just awesome to see.
-You guys, I think like
people don't understand how
difficult it is,
what Jimmy does for a living,
like as a talk show host.
Like the amount of stuff
that you have to kind of
keep up with every day
is incredible.
And, every time since I was 15,
I've come on this show
and you've just been
the best guy ever, truly.
I mean that, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Do you want to --
Would you like to interview me?
-Should I?
-Yes!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Don't fall, Shawn.
♪♪
-[ Clears throat ]
-Jimmy.
-Oh, my God!
-Ah, this feels better.
-Wow! Interesting.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This feels small.
I feel so small.
-And I'm back at the mini table.
[ Laughter ]
-You look so much
more powerful than me, yeah.
Shawn, I'm so happy to be here.
I love this crowd.
New York City!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Jimmy Fallon, everybody.
Jimmy.
-Roots!
-We love you here.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-We do. We really do. I have
a couple questions for you.
How have you been, good?
-Yes, I've been good.
-You look great. New suit?
-Thanks for asking.
-Yes, it's a brand-new suit.
I just got for the show.
I got dressed up for you.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. So let me ask you
a question, right?
-Like, Follow, or Block.
You got Niall Horan...
[ Cheering and applause ]
-That's my boy.
-...Justin Timberlake...
[ Cheering and applause ]
...and Shawn Mendes.
You have to choose.
-Like, Follow, Block?
-Yeah, Like, Follow, Block.
-Niall...
[ Laughter ]
-He's watching.
-"He's watching."
-...like.
-Like?
-Like Niall.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Not enough to follow him, eh?
-Block Justin Timberlake.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering, ohs, and applause ]
-Just because he's blocked me.
[ Laughter ]
So that's why.
I feel like he's tired
of hearing from me, yeah.
-He's not.
-And I will follow
-No, he's not.
-Shawn Mendes, yeah.
I will follow, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Justin, call me, please!
Call me, Justin!
[ Laughter ]
I like that.
That's a good question.
Any other?
-Yeah.
-What?
-Well, would you rather be
the fastest or the strongest
or the smartest person
in the world?
I really want to know this one.
What would you, fastest,
strongest, or smartest?
-Fastest, strongest,
or smartest?
-Yeah.
-I think I already am
the fastest,
[ Laughter ]
so I don't have to worry
about that.
I think smartest, for me --
-You think you're faster
than me?
[ Ohs ]
-I do think I'm --
-You do?
-Prove it!
[ Drumroll ]
I mean, you're tall,
a little bit taller.
-You noticed how long
my legs are.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you're taller,
but, I mean,
I think that takes you longer
to get like
some speed...
-You're fast?
[ Laughter ]
-...you know?
Yeah, I'm fast.
You want to have a race?
-You want to race me?
I'll race you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You want to race?
Where do we go,
from here to The Roots?
♪♪
-To the drums?
-Alright, we'll go here
to the drums.
You don't even know
your way around.
There's dresser drawers
right there
and stuff.
Be careful.
Wait. Are you getting
a head start?
-Why is there a flashlight
back here?
-Oh, that not a flashlight.
-I don't know what that is.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Whoa. Be careful.
[ Laughter ]
Alright. That's a lightsaber.
Alright, you ready for this?
-I didn't stretch.
-On your mark, get set, go.
♪♪
[ Cheering ]
Both times.
[ Laughter ]
Shawn Mendes, everybody.
I'm winded.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Shawn's performing his new song,
"When You're Gone"
later in the show.
For tickets
for Wonder: The World Tour,
they're on sale right now.
Jesse Tyler Ferguson
joins us after the break.
Stick around.